my mouth hurts so bad I'm trying so hard
Italy just a story about my life that's
the show
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings
and today I'm joined by Olympic figure
skater Adam rip on he's the breakout
star the 2018 Winter Games a bronze
medal winner who stole the hearts of
millions on the ice and off and he can
catch him the 2018 Stars on Ice tour
coming to a city near you Adam
welcome to the show Jon thanks for
having me so you've been doing
round-the-clock press I can only imagine
that you just want to go home and take a
nap what's going through your head now
that you pulled up a seat at this circus
Sean I won the hearts of millions and
now I'm ready to just [ __ ] my brains I
feel like pretty good with everything
and then the ones with like the
explosives are where I'm worried
[Music]
and then reverse this Oh like this yeah
okay I got it
okay Jesus Christ
Oh this is actually delicious okay I'm
all worried as I can taste like a pepper
so there's so much about the games that
we don't get to see so if you'll humor
me I'm curious about your experience off
the ice
can I talk with my mouth phone yeah you
get a long leash here on hot ones okay
which country do you think got the best
fit off during the opening ceremonies
Sean you know that it's a guy from Tonga
in college hat it's like Sub Zero and
you're going there greased-up listen
I've done that before
it's not pretty I'm gonna die here as
somebody in their first Olympics with a
spotlight on you what's the pressure to
perform like does it feel that much
heavier than the other major events in
your career you know the Olympics is
such a funny event when you walk in and
it's just like every other arena you've
ever competed in the part that you don't
ever get prepared for is all of the
media and for me that meant going into
the media just saying what was on my
mind being a little trashy having a
little fun
Sean you'd know me well enough now you
know I like little fun very happy to
have you in the seat I feel comfortable
in this seat it's a nice seat we
actually just upgraded the chairs to
yeah I can tell this is a nice
leatherette
I'd be lying if I didn't tell you that I
was heading into some jumps and I was
like if I [ __ ] this up Leslie Jones is
gonna be like blasting my ass on Twitter
she didn't know because I didn't mess it
up
yama is delish
i love this one louisiana mm-hmm and the
bronx is so good hey well stack them up
we'll put them in your bag Adam I want
to talk about the Adam rip on effect in
the media because it was crazy to see in
real time from where Isaac I could only
imagine was like from your perspective
and in particular I noticed it's your
finger snapping swagger it's like Chum
in the water for a lot of these bloggers
that want to make Internet friendly news
pieces so what I want to do is read four
headlines about you and I want you to
tell me which one wasn't written by a
major media organization okay okay nine
amazing add a rip on quotes that'll make
you go Yass Adam rip on says he's a hot
mess why Adam rip on is the woke Bay we
don't deserve and Olympic glamazon Adam
rip on says haters are as motivators my
dad must be so proud I'm gonna say why
is that a rip on the wolf Bay we don't
deserve ding ding ding ding ding I know
I nailed it I know that you know your
headline yes I do
I'm the meme we've been looking for the
meme we don't deserve the meme that
makes us say Yas yes
[Music]
mmm good I'm afraid of the one that's
read I think that's still in there like
not top three territory but it flirts
with Noel I fire it - mm-hmm
I'm tinder you know the Olympic Village
has this reputation for being this sex
fueled Mardi Gras and I wonder what were
your expectations of it going into it
and then what's the reality of the
situation
expectations condom brothel reality not
a little more tame than you were
expecting
yeah I was expecting hot box orgy and
what I got was stress box diarrhea and
then there's that great story about you
eating in and out on the roof with me
Rinna gasps ooh lamenting the fact that
you didn't make the Olympics four and a
half years ago if you were eating a
double-double now with the same magical
impact on your life where do you think
you'll be four and a half years from now
all I have to say is those in and out
meets those are magic meets so basically
if you are depressed eat a burger and
four years later you'll go to the
Olympics
[Music]
what's your mentality just take one bite
and you're like I did the thing so at
this point I don't feel like I have tons
of proof but I'll kind of mirror that's
debatable
I'll mirror the guest you know what I
mean so the more hammer the guest is
going on the wings the more hammer I'll
go on the wings if the guest is kind of
just puttin their feet in the shallow
end then I'll just put my feet in the
shallow end all right no so wherever you
go I'll go Adam you drive all right I've
been driving all right we have a
recurring segment on our show called
explain that Graham where I do a deep
dive and I guess Instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context who top bust out the laptop I'll
show you the picture and you tell me the
bigger story does that sound good
mm-hmm there's a hot then I thought it
was originally yeah all right first
things first
Oh needs to call me Barry Bonds Little
League throwback mm-hmm he should be a
baseball player
here's the thing I wasn't good no and I
wasn't great
I was actually terrible so I actually
this is what that was a hot one get it
uh I'm getting worried um and then one
time I went up to bat as they say that's
our lingo and I got hit by the pitch I
started crying and I like take a base if
you get hit by a pitch you take a base
and I was like nice yeah so then I got
in trouble with my parents because I'd
go up to bat and I'd be like uh and get
hit by the pitches all the time I said
the moral of that story you got to do
what you got to do to help the team win
thank you
you took the words right out of my mouth
there you go at him this is pre Oscars
with Jeremy Scott yes so I love me some
Jeremy Scott because I think Jeremy
Scott is a genius and he's crazy and his
ideas are bizarre and wild and I'm crazy
bizarre and wild some people called me a
genius like I don't agree like I do a
little like I understand
and when Jeremy took the classic tuxedo
and he took the shoulders out when we
added that harness to it where it felt
like you were kind of strapped into the
tuxedo I just felt really [ __ ] cool
and when we were first doing it Jeremy's
like don't wear a shirt and I was like
you're right I shouldn't do that and
then the whole team around me was like
Adam you're gonna wear a shirt and I was
like oh yeah you're right it's the
Oscars so it could have been even more
you could have just pushed it even more
almost sober up to you if it were up to
me I would always push it more oh god
yeah I'm getting it well that hurts my
throat still go in though I came here
hungry I'm gonna leave here sick so one
of the things that separates Figure
Skating from everything else is the
soundtrack how important is the music to
the routine the music is so important a
lot of high-level skaters work with a DJ
- like customize this tracks so a lot of
times even if it's a song that sounds
familiar it's a completely like
remastered track specifically for that
skater and specifically for the way the
elements are set in the program so you
feel like wow this is really like a
performance made for that and it's
because it is what's the most played out
song to skate - recently been allowed to
skate - lyrics in the last four years
which opens up the catalogue Oh fully so
you can skate - literally whatever you
want I could honestly if I wanted to
skate - the audio of this interview if I
wanted to listen maybe I'm asking the
wrong person maybe I'm barking up the
wrong tree but how is it that ya a
figure skater can pull a song and then
they can play whatever song and then
broadcast it on TV all over the globe
but then on hot ones I can't sing along
to a t-pain track and clear it how do
you sound when you
the teeth I was doing on somebody hard I
was doing go hard with t-pain and then
and then we cut up the episode and then
we tried to put it out and then like
legal was like whoa we can't clear this
really yeah I'm like getting bleeped and
stuff that's don't they take my voice
and they hide it from the world
that's not fair people tried to do that
to me to ones and I said uh-huh not
anymore I won't get scared until I get
to the next one but this is the one that
scares me because it's red going in this
is hot but it's really enjoyable all
right Adam like you have once had
Olympic dreams I made some noise and
juniors but due to an Achilles injury I
had to hang up the skates but in honor
of your appearance here me and Chris we
went over to that rink in Central Park
and put together a hot ones free skate
for you so I'm gonna play you the
footage that we pulled basically you can
just score it like you would as a judge
you can let me know if I still got it
okay
so here's me hitting it wow this is
great
Wow you look like you have a lot of
support emotional though
[Music]
and oh oh nice fork that's beautiful
oh you are very into the upper body do
the judges like stuff like that yeah I
think so I mean as a judge in this
situation I really enjoyed it right
there is when you see the Achilles
injury really come through and then you
know I think that there's three major
parts to rounding out your skating
persona you're right there's the costume
body and soul those three things but on
the costume side right what a full-on
sriracha bottle 1zb too much I almost
say too little why didn't you do that
why are you looking back now and being
like I [ __ ] up well I'm just laying
the groundwork you know what I mean are
you boiled in Beijing exactly I I didn't
want to say it I'm glad you did
what song do you think I should skate -
probably the t-pain song that you
weren't allowed to hear on the show and
then what about this signature move cuz
I was thinking about going with this
bottle sauce shake move but I don't want
anything to get lost in translation yeah
oh that see that was lost on me
that's not originally where my head had
gone
I appreciated the intent don't do that
yeah now I'm scared but now I'm scared I
don't know why I said it I heard myself
saying that oh somebody got really
nervous when I did that
hey this one's hot hot well mmm are you
putting up a front Adam or is this like
for real you're just no problem it's
like warm oh my god
you're a [ __ ] there are a lot of times
in competition where you feel like [ __ ]
but I always put on this calm and cool
front and I'm doing that right now
yeah I'm I'm trying not to talk because
like the wind from my voice is like
making my body hurt right now well
speaking of you recently set the record
straight on an internet rumor that you
had butt pads during competition
tweeting no it's just my real butt
thank you for your interest but as
anyone who follows you on Instagram
knows it's the ABS that are the real
star of the show can you give me some
tips on how to get Adam rip on ripped
for summer leg raises am i doing cable
crunches all the above what do I need to
do to get that eight-pack can I spit and
yeah yeah you wouldn't be the first one
it just felt like extra spit I didn't
need so I work on my core every single
day this is honestly like terrible yeah
yeah
ABB's recover really quickly they'll
recover in a day so you can work on them
every single day so I balance that in
with cardio get the blood flowing do all
of those crunches you're doing leg lifts
you do a lot of stuff like overextending
the ABS and then bringing them up so
that you can stretch them out come in
[Applause]
how about those pesky lower abs because
sometimes I can kind of frame it out up
top it's just it doesn't snap together
in the lower abs I think one thing that
might help if you aren't having so much
[ __ ] chicken I'm not my lips hurt
yeah
so something like I can't help but like
I can't keep spitting but I can't stop
drooling what did you say I'm like going
into a blackout why who did this
this show is [ __ ]
now so we can't have an atom rep on
interview without talking about your
Twitter game the clap backs the
motivational messages they become the
stuff of an internet legend when you're
scrolling your Twitter mentions what are
the things that you see that warm your
heart and what are the things that you
see that make you want to throw your
phone under a Zamboni nice nod to the
equipment it's often not appreciated I'm
gonna tell you a few tips the trade the
things that I love there are some crazy
talented fans that I have put together
fan art I just keep this very close yeah
just like the ends essence of a mother's
milk I love when somebody is kind of
sassy to me but in a funny way where I
can tell that they're just being fun I
love when people tweet at me and they
say thanks dad I love that I do get some
hate on Twitter that's true but I don't
respond to anything unless the person
writing the tweet is just completely
stupid and I like to respond to like
completely stupid
does this count as cardio just the kind
that gives you the top abs yeah not
those lower low Roger that the pesky
lowers yeah not the pesky bottoms I've
run into a few of them recently
this is the last dab we call it the last
dab because it's a tradition around here
to put a little extra on the last wing
I just went berserk on that try to make
a smaller dab than that should you dare
to do it very deliberate oh yeah
all right that's a pesky bottom you call
that a pesky bottom look at this pesky
bottom the fire dad impressed the whole
show I'm so sorry this is like your work
and you have to come back him all right
do you take a bite of that that would be
the point oh that's why we did that yeah
all right my friend all right Cheers
Adam
[Music]
[Music]
okay no um I think you've lost control
of like the upper half of my body okay
Adam it might been an inspiration to
many and now that you have a trillion
scovilles going through you I want to
know what's your message to the people
who said that you couldn't slay on the
biggest international stage and to the
people who didn't think that you'd take
down the wings of death to my haters
that thought I wouldn't do this to my
doubters who thought that this wouldn't
happen there will be some naysayers the
fuck'em we did it we did it my man I saw
The Olympian in you
I saw the mind over matter I saw the guy
who would go in for extra bites even
when he was at his edge and now look at
you with a glow with a shine it's like
the podium all over again and now
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you my friend this
camera this camera or this camera let
the people know what you have going on
in your life you guys come to Stars on
ice go to stars on ice calm we're coming
to 22 cities find out one that's near
you also you can go to Just Giving calm
slash Adam reppin and give to my GLAAD
initiative I'm working with their Youth
Ambassador Program also follow me on
Twitter and Instagram it's really fun
[Music]
it was good you know I didn't know that
like this part of my face would hurt the
last three or novelty yeah I'm floating
hey what's going on hot ones fans and
Sean Evans checking in if you enjoyed
the video do us a solid please subscribe
we're not above begging for clout over
here so you know what to do
smash that subscribe button with a
sledgehammer who appreciates you me